so we're there there's no reception we
keep trying to call this oh there is no
reception okay so it's 2010 the Lakers
are facing the Celtics and it's game 7
I'm trying to get tickets to go to it
finally an attorney sells me these nice
tickets for $6,000 and I said I'm gonna
call a friend I call my friend pastor
Dudley brother if I said woody he's a
big diehard Lakers fan he says let me
think about it so he offers to take the
car I said I'll Drive you myself I pull
up I pick him up by my office he gets in
this yellow zo6 that I have and we're
flying on the way there the 210 freeway
which is known for having a worst
reception because of the mountains my
zo6 runs out of gas and by the way if
you don't know I have the reputation for
having grant out of gas in my cars at
least 50 times maybe more so we're there
there's no reception we keep trying to
call this on there is no reception
finally we get a bar we call the guy
shows up from triple-a he knows me by my
first name pastor Dudley Rutherford's
making fun of me saying how does a
triple-a guy know you by your first name
gives me guess he's recording the entire
video we get back in the car we barely
make it
first quarter starts we make it to the
game and obviously the Lakers beat the
Celtics that I think they win their 16th
championship it was a great game we come
back home I'm over I thought this is the
story right now I got a reputation on
the San Fernando Valley as a business
guys an entrepreneur I'm kind of shaking
it up I got some enemies I got some
competitors but I'm built on a
reputation right it's been built but
it's getting bigger and bigger so pastor
doesn't he calls me three weeks late he
says listen I want you to come to
service because I got a store I want you
to be sitting front row all the sudden
some call no problem you want me front
row I go I bring my dad I bring my wife
we're sitting in front oh he invited me
so I go sit in the front row and he gets
up he said I want to tell you story
about a good friend of mine Patrick bad
David can you stand up please so I stand
up you know it's kind of like ol hey Lee
up thinking this is like this is this is
a great business guy all this other
stuff and he said Patrick offers to take
me to a Laker game and let me tell you
what happens on the way to a Laker game
and he tells the entire story by the way
his church is 15,000 members he said it
at five different services and it
doesn't stop there let me tell what else
happens he writes a book with a major
publisher and the title the book is God
has an app for that if you buy the book
chapter number one tells you vividly how
I ran out of gas and at the end of the
book he has a link on his website for
you to see how I ran out of gas while
he's recording my yellow zo6 now keep in
mind the rest of the time and valley
every time I went to some other people
say aren't you
I said yeah that's Patrick wait David
aren't you together ran out of gas you
two got there always runs out of gas oh
my gosh now it was embarrassing as a
businessman but on the other side it
became one of the best conversation
starters and San Fernando Valley so
Thank You Dudley Rutherford to tell the
story of me running out of gas it helped
me in business